and but in his mind the story was so
good just like our friend jesse smollett
in his mind his story was so good and he
also did media again all these people
with these terrible stories who were
like i should go do a live interview and
incriminate myself
don't don't give any interviews jessie
smellet no no give interviews including
prince andrew more interviews we need
everyone jessie smallette testifies
today
i couldn't believe it
they're saying this guy may be convicted
as soon as tomorrow oh my gosh jesse
smallett by the time you guys so we're
live right now we record this but
tomorrow morning this one's going to go
up and it may be but by the time you
find this video smilet has already been
found guilty by a jury of his peers
because it has been a disaster in this
case yeah they were experts were saying
the only defense he has is for him to
testify and it's
let's you got to hear this if you've not
been following this you are grab the
popcorn you are gonna laugh
so first this guy claims
the defense that the osindairo brothers
that he hired according to the
prosecutors to stage this hoax are
sophisticated criminals who framed him
they planned the whole thing
even though he paid them for workout
training and then told the cops they
were white they planned the whole thing
to frame him why because they're
homophobic and they hate him
then you get the uh what happens is
during during testimony the defense
tries cross-examining one of the
osindairo brothers and the judge said
that it was like collateral or something
in a move on and so
you just get ready for the suspense
they the the the the defense attorney
calls for a sidebar to speak with the
judge
demands a mistrial because they were
saying that they're not being properly
allowed to cross-examine then claims the
judge lunged at her
demands a mistrial over that the judge
says that's bs that never happened and
you're not getting a mistrial
and then the defense started crying and
left the courtroom with her mother
i am not making that up the attorney yes
left with her mother
what is happening let me i i'm gonna is
this not on camera how this is uh this
is a violation of our human rights
the whole cast of empire is watching
this like this show is fantastic
i would have to say that jesse smollett
is trying to use the kevin spacey
defense if you remember kevin spacey was
accused of doing some absolutely
horrendous horrible things to underaged
children particularly boys and his main
defense was hey i'm gay and because of
that the mainstream corporate press
literally ran with headlines brave actor
kevin spacey comes out as gay and that
somehow obfuscated that the larger
accusations very serious accusations of
him doing horrible things to small
children and now jesse smullet's main
argument here is that he's gay and he
does gay stuff that's his main defense
exclusively here and when that's your
defense
i don't think you have a winning case
here no it's a lifestyle not a defense
and all right it's crazy all right so i
pulled this up we got breitbart and we
got the new york post on thursday
smallest attorney tamara walker
requested a mistrial over her claims
cook county judge james lynn
physically lunged at her cbs news
reports reports say the encounter
happened during a sidebar conversation
with attorneys from both sides the judge
denied the accusations and also denied
the motion for mistrial walker
reportedly appeared to be close to tears
while debating with the judge and left
the courtroom with her mother while the
rest of smilet's team continued to ask
for a measure okay close to tears sorry
i said she cried she was close to tears
as she left with her mother that is
jesse smallett's defense team if your
defense lawyer cries out for mommy in
the courtroom
that's a bad sign
that's bad you know what happened was
she went up and was like saying
something to judge and get in his face
and he went
like he leaned at her and went i am the
law here and got real serious and then
she considered that like an attack but
he's like establishing order i'm
pro that's that's probably exactly what
happened you know yeah
she brought her mom with her is she like
fresh out of law school and like it's
her first trial and jessie's like i'm
gonna i'm gonna give her a chance you
know on my life to like leave the
defense yeah the new york post reports
the same thing she was near tears and
she left the she left the court with her
mother who was in the gallery as the
rest of smart's team continued to ask
for a mistrial did jesse did juicy smell
it hire l wood from
legally legally blind no no legally
blonde and like maybe he's hoping she'll
have her breakthrough moment in the
courtroom you know and she'll realize
that that he's innocent i mean
this is one comment that i'm seeing uh
right now and it's uh that jesus millet
the first american to scam nigerians
that's what we're finding out through
this square proceeding and i think they
have a point good lord but he actually
testified
and uh let's read this from cnn they say
former empire star uh jesse smallett
took the stand and the star i like i'm
sorry they said actor i said i i made it
up it said former empire actor jesus
malette took the stand in the ongoing
criminal trial monday in a high stakes
attempt to rebut charges that he staged
a fake hate crime
they say under oath monday millet
offered testimony over more than two
hours that suggested the brothers whom
he knew from the empire set may have had
other motivations
he said bola osindairo who he called bon
helped get him drugs including cocaine
he also said they had a sexual
relationship between them at a
particular chicago bathhouse one night
while the tour out and smellette
testified they got a private room and
did drugs and like made out on a
separate occasion smilet told jurors he
and bola snuck away from from his
brother after the three were at a female
strip club together so that testified
again they got a private room and made
out a little bit and uh family-friendly
show you know uh had fun together let's
just i don't i don't have relationships
i don't know how this is you don't need
to go there i imagine you're the jury
jeffrey
together
if you're the jury and he's just saying
all this stuff you're like yo i don't
know what this has to do with anything
so they say
he kind of creeped me out every time we
were around him he didn't speak to me
every time we needed to leave he made it
seem like we needed to sneak off after a
hate letter was sent to him smallette
said bola osandaro approached him about
becoming his personal security guard
something the actor told the jury
osandaro had repeatedly asked him
following the letter bola sander began
asking him more about the need for
security some of that said they are
described being annoyed at the idea of
always having a security detail detail
around him
around lunchtime i would smoke my blunt
drive around the neighborhood of the
studios i don't want to be in someone's
car somewhere told the jury that while
driving around with bola there was never
any discussion of planning a staged hate
attack did you talk to him about some
hoax no smolette said so it sounds like
jesse smallett's argument is this guy
staged the attack because he was trying
to convince him to hire him as a
security guard
and that i mean that's a story i don't
see any evidence to claim that's true
because smollett paid him
for personal training and the idea that
these guys were white went that's what
mullet said which is like he lied
you know yeah so so if they did this to
convince you that you needed security
you called the cops but you didn't and
immediately point to them these are the
guys who did it you didn't and you were
still wearing the noose and you still
had your soda and your subway sandwich
they did a dry run of
they have they have the nigerian
brothers go into a store and literally
pick up black masks right the rope that
they used and and
they he wrote a checkup to them yeah
well on tomorrow's show if he is found
guilty and you have this breaking news
for the show um i i tweeted a couple of
days ago that i think his punishment
should be very simple he should have to
go to the next maga rally and he should
have to look at the president trump and
he should have to apologize
don't put him in jail it's a waste of
taxpayer dollars for him to go to jail
he should have to repay all of the legal
work and the and the police work
investigating says that they're gonna
potentially charge him hundreds of
thousands of dollars for that larger
investigation it's a waste of it he's
gonna get killed in jail probably i
don't think he's going to get it he
shouldn't go to jail but for those of us
people who are in camp maga who they
made a huge deal of this in 19 and he
did the whole press circuit and they
were like this is indicative of the
types of people who vote for donald
trump for all of us who who proudly
voted for donald trump who were sick and
tired of being besmirched by people like
juicy smolette he owes us an apology and
we should get a sincere one and a
sincere one for me is being in front of
tens of thousands of us don't write us a
little letter or do a youtube video you
have to stand there and face us and
listen to us either heckle you or
know and trump people they'll probably
give them a little applause and say get
them off the stage i just feel like i'm
kind of done trying to convince people
who are in the cult people who believed
this story the people who believe the
covington lies the people believe
russiagate ukraine gate all that garbage
who fell for the lie after laughter lie
and each and every one of those stories
has been definitively debunked the media
lied yeah what's the point of trying to
convince people who want to be lied to
that they've been lied to i mean justice
malet apparently has supporters outside
the courtroom like cheering for him
whatever look serial killers get it too
man serial killers have get letters from
ladies who are like i love you you know
so whatever man um what's the point i
think a regular person hears the story
and they immediately just are like yeah
okay that's bs and i'm like there we go
what more do we need to be saying about
this i'm glad though
because i do think justice justice
millet is contributing to the people
waking up to what's going on yeah
because we had big bang theory with the
you know they did the group photo and
everyone coming out and being like i
can't believe this happened and blaming
trump supporters and it was just very
obviously not true yeah
yeah and it's a frustrating thing
because it also does an awful lot of
damage to
uh people who are attacked real i don't
i don't believe in hate crimes i don't
believe in hate speech
but we use that term uh but but but it
does do a lot of damage to people who
are victims of crime you know and also
how many police resources were diverted
right it's the same thing of like the
bubba watson incident how many fbi
agents does it take to go investigate a
nascar right one if these resources are
so limited and so expensive how many
people chicago this year it just hit its
eight and it's your home city i like to
talk about new york as well chicago just
hit it it's 800th homicide this year how
many detectives could have been diverted
to the streets to whatever but we're
doing the jesse smollett investigation
right so those are the people who
deserve the true apology you stole
resources from a very very tortured city
it's true it's true but i also got to
say like chicago's got very serious
problems with police corruption and
they've always had it's been a mob town
as long as i've known it and if you look
at history it's always been a mob town
and i'm kind of like torn between
yeah maybe there could be some cops
stopping you know some of these gun
crimes and homicides and stuff but then
i remember when chicago operated black
sites where they arrested people without
charge and held them there for 10 days
not notifying anybody or when that one
guy was electrocuting people to force
confessions so at that point i'm kind of
like i don't know whatever i'm not going
to give them anything we got tracked
down by the chicago pd and had a you
know
i had a gun pointed at me because of
just journalism
yeah we got surrounded by a bunch of
cars they took the cop cars unmarked
some marked took us out searched us it
was all completely unwarranted
they apparently raided the apartment we
were staying at the whole crazy story
went down they tried planting drugs on
us just real real dirty stuff chicago is
a dirty city
they there's i can't remember the guy's
name do you guys remember the name of
the guy in chicago who is cattle
prodding people into forcing him to
confessions
yeah i'm not a fan of the cpd whatever
happened to the that black site that the
chicago police department was running do
you know much about it it was uh common
square is that what it was called home
and square home and square looked it up
yeah yeah no it was unmarked location
where they would bring people to like
you know effectively torture
you know
city at war man does that still operate
i don't know i haven't been in chicago i
i moved out of chicago uh 13 years ago
yeah 13 years ago
and uh get ready that story broke in
2015. yeah that's nuts it's crazy right
so
look man
i like the idea of you know the good
local cop who's like look i just want to
make sure people aren't getting hurt and
i've met some of these guys but you look
at some of these big cities like new
york chicago and la and they are crooked
super crooked new york is super crooked
chicago's super crooked the small towns
you tend to tend to be okay but you look
at a lot of cops who are willing to just
do what they're told yeah i kind of
agree with you daniel about i don't
think putting him in jail solves
anything at this point but but like a a
public apology might actually do more
good for society yeah for jesse i don't
know
yeah at least for me i want my apology
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm now don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you